bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 12
janvier les surveillants de la prison de
bois d'arcy en colère et solidaires ils
ont manifesté vendredi pour soutenir 3
de leur collègue agressé la veille dans
le nord de la france par un détenu
condamné pour terrorisme
certains sont inquiètes d'autres s'en
félicite l'arrivée des sciences
cognitives à l'école l'étude du
fonctionnement du cerveau pour améliorer
l'apprentissage est ce vraiment efficace
utile nous en parlerons notamment avec
notre invité fil rouge bertrand mesures
représentant du syndicat snuipp fsu pour
les yvelines dans le reste de
l'actualité retour sur l'hommage à
clarisse à la policière yvelinoise a
battu lors des attentes des attentats de
janvier 2015 ou encore la vie des
professionnels de la route sur
l'abaissement de la vitesse pour
renforcer la sécurité routière mans
débutent donc cette émission avec de la
colère celle des surveillants
pénitentiaires après l'agression à la
prison de vendin-le-vieil jeudi dans le
pas de calais un détenu radicalisées a
attaqué et blessé trois gardiens au
moment de sortir pour téléphoner ce
vendredi plusieurs syndicats a appelé à
un mouvement national de soutien à la
maison d'arrêt de bois d'arcy les
surveillants ont débrayé à 13 heures
pendant 15 minutes c'était au moment de
l'appel leurs revendications au micro de
grégory canal et donc on est dans une
réaction de colère dernièrement passe on
déclare depuis des années des détenus
radicaliser sur l'établissement
pénitentiaire or à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
on n'a aucun établissement pénitentiaire
qui est capable de gérer ces détenus
donc nous notre organisation syndicale
on demande la création d'établissement
pénitentiaire spécialisé pour les
détenus radicaliser ou en voie de
radicalisation et pour être complet sur
le sujet sachez que les représentants
des syndicats ont pu rencontrer vendredi
la direction de la maison d'arrêt de
bois d'arcy très à l'écouté
selon eux
d'autres mouvements pourraient cependant
avoir lieu dans les prochains jours les
voeux du medef aussi dans l'actualité
jeudi une célébration à versailles ou
chefs d'entreprise députés ou encore
élus locaux étaient présents un moment
pour évoquer les attentes du patronat
dans le département en rapport avec les
réformes du gouvernement
écoutez à ce propos le président du
medef yvelines bertrand de créer et le
député yvelinois de la république en
marche didier baichère les projets du
gouvernement nous satisfait les annonces
faites en tout cas quand on nous parle
ministration
qui va nous accompagner qui va dialoguer
qui va qu'on nous pas le droit à
l'erreur
tout cela ça va dans le bon sens
s'étaient rencontrés dès le mois de juin
avec le medef et on a proposé d'avoir un
rythme de travail trimestriels avec eux
justement pour évaluer les textes de loi
sur lequel on travaille donc on s'est
mis dans ce mode de collaboration avec
le medef 78 rencontrer régulièrement des
groupements d'entreprises pour tester
c'est ce qui s'est passé pour le projet
pacte en fait sur les sites m
le traité par bercy il ya un binôme chef
d'entreprise député qui travaille les
sujets en amont pour qu'en fait la loi
qui sortent sur le plus adapté aux
besoins des entreprises
faut-il y voir une nouvelle approche
positive pour l'éducation nationale
l'amorcé d'un mouvement d'un
chamboulement profond pour l'école le
conseil scientifique de l'éducation
nationale a été officiellement installé
mercredi par le ministre jean michel
blanc coeur ce nouvel organe est dirigée
par un scientifique un spécialiste des
sciences cognitives précisément une
nouveauté qui inquiète certains acteurs
du monde éducatif pour en parler
bertrand mesure est avec nous au plateau
bonsoir monsieur vous êtes le co
secrétaire départemental du syndicat
snui pp fsu syndicat majoritaire pour le
premier degré comment vous vous percevez
cette arrivée des sciences cognitives
dans l'univers éducatif ça faisait déjà
quelques temps là ça semble s'accélérer
avec le nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale quel est votre point de vue
sur le sujet faut-il s'en inquiéter ou
alors vous êtes plutôt observateurs pour
le moment va écouter l'arrivée des
sciences cognitives dans l'éducation
nationale ça date pas du conseil
scientifique mis en place bref monsieur
blanc caire puisque pour ceux qui encore
quelques souvenirs nous avions jean
piaget qui à l'époque avait développé
fait fait avancer beaucoup les sciences
cognitives et en particulier en ce qui
concernait l'épistémologie chez le jeune
enfant et qui avait mis en évidence
toute une série d'avancées sur la façon
dont les enfants
on a l'impression il n'y a pas de sujet
cas précis beaucoup à michel blanc caire
alors on en parle souvent jean michel
blanquer r est un peu dans la même
philosophie que celle qu'il avait quand
il travaillait avec monsieur de revient
c'est à dire que il est dans la
philosophie d'une solution miracle à
toutes les difficultés de l'école serait
pas jusqu'à dire que c'est une vision un
peu mécaniste mais on est un peu dans
cette dans cette vision là c'est pas
parce qu'on observe que au moment d'une
opération cognitives telles ou telles
zones du cerveau s'active et que tel
exercice active la même zone du cerveau
que pour autant on peut faire des liens
de causalité que d'ailleurs monsieur
dehaene ne fait pas quand on lit soit
celui qui dirige le nouveau à l'arrêt
quand il quand on l'interrogé il est
beaucoup plus humble dans les propos que
peut l'être
monsieur blanc caire en particulier sur
la connaissance fine que l'on peut avoir
du cerveau et de ses mécanismes les plus
intimes et sur la sq que peut produire
l'arrivée de ces conceptions sur le
travail quotidien des enseignants alors
voir on va peut-être préciser rapidement
ce que sont les sciences cognitives
c'est en quelque sorte et très
vulgairement l'étude scientifique du
cerveau de son fonctionnement pour ceux
qui défendent ces sciences l'a ensuite
mettre en place des méthodes
pédagogiques plus efficace pour
l'apprentissage des élèves
est-ce que ça ça parle concrètement aux
professeurs sur le terrain est ce que
c'est des choses qui les intéressent et
ce que certains comprennent activement
ce que ça veut dire et mettre en place
des jades est tout à fait je sais ce que
je vous disais par exemple tous les tous
les tests piège essien qui avait été
fait à l'époque avaient irrigué
l'ensemble de l'éducation nationale
parfois avec beaucoup de d'excès et puis
on était revenu en arrière c'est à dire
qu'à chaque fois l'éducation nationale
et les enseignants se saisissent des
opportunités qui leur sont donnés deux
d'améliorer leurs pratiques mais tout en
restant assez sensible au contexte
général de la classe et à ce qu'est un
individu à jeunes enfants dans son
ensemble on ne peut pas réduire le
comportement et le comment dirais-je la
vie d'un enfant à quelques images de
fustel particulièrement bien comment
repérer par rapport à une telle ou telle
compétence certains professeurs s'en
méfier aussi énormément refusent
d'appliquer ce type de les méthodes qui
sont préconisées par imposer mais
préconisé si vous voulez les les on est
toujours un peu sceptique c'est à dire
que la question qui était de savoir à
une époque on devait être tout tout
syllabique en sait bien que la méthode
syllabique a beaucoup de défauts que la
métairie pour apprendre à lire voilà que
la méthode globale n'a jamais quasiment
jamais été appliquée en france et que la
plupart des enseignants des méthodes
mixtes et que les voies d'apprentissage
chez les enfants peuvent être très
différents d'un enfant à l'autre
donc il s'agit de conserver une certaine
distance par rapport à ça maintenant je
si on est sur ce registre là moi
j'inviterai aussi nos ministres à
utiliser les mêmes sciences cognitives
pour la sphère politique pour la sphère
économique et peut-être ainsi à
découvrir dès comment dirais-je des
pistes insoupçonnée dans la façon de
vous pensé à moi concrètement parfois
quand on voit le comportement de
certains hommes politiques ou de
certaines décisions politiques on peut
se demander s'ils ont fait l'objet d'une
image d'une imagerie médicale
certainement pas vous êtes d'accord
quand même avec la vie sous jacent avec
cette ces sciences cognitives qui arrive
sur ce sur ce constat que l'école
française et notamment l'école primaire
n'est plus vraiment efficace que c'est
pour ça que les élèves français décroche
dans les classements internationaux
justement je vais vous n'avez pas
j'imagine la même là même à preuve un
comble je dirais que les élèves ont
commencé à décrocher à partir du moment
où monsieur blanc caire a fait partie du
cabinet de monsieur d'eurovia donc avant
de s'intéresser aux sciences cognitives
il serait peut-être bon qu'il
s'intéresse à à ce que lui-même a mis en
place à l'époque et les résultats que
cela a produit puisque si on regarde les
résultats qui ont été actuellement
produit c'est ceux qui sont issus de la
politique qu'il avait mis en place à
l'époque donc je crois que il faut
raison garder et et peut-être aussi
faire preuve de beaucoup d'humilité je
crois que tout ce qui tend à vouloir
faire comprendre au public à l'école
comme ailleurs il suffit d'appuyer sur
un bouton pour avoir un résultat est une
politique qui ne peut qu être vouée à
l'échec à l'école primaire connaît en ce
moment d'importantes transformations en
tout cas ces dernières semaines avec
notamment à la rentrée on s'en rappelle
la mise en place de cp à 12 dans les
réseaux d'éducation prioritaire c'est le
cas notamment dans certaines classes à
attrape ici sur le je vous arrête tout
de suite de cp à 12 dans les réseaux
d'éducation prioritaire ce n'est pas
vrai c'est donc en cale sèche
voilà les raids plus qu'on appelle j'ai
oublié l'euro fort si vous faites bien
de
le souligner parce que c'est loin de
correspondre la somme de l'éducation
prioritaire et c'est loin de
correspondre à l'ensemble ça va se
déployer justement c'est sensé se
déployer sur les rentrée prochaine
justement pour couvrir l'ensemble des
drm et puis dès ses 20 aussi est-ce que
vous avez des même si c'est peu de
classe on en comprend est-ce que vous
avez des premiers retours et si oui
est-ce qu'ils sont positifs
alors écoutez évidemment que les retours
sont positifs puisque c'est une demande
constante des enseignants et c'est aussi
une contestation des constatations
internationale puisque ont évoqué des
éléments scientifiques
toutes les études scientifiques ont
démontré que la diminution du nombre
d'élèves par classe était un facteur de
réussite pour les élèves
alors là en l'occurrence c'est assez
massif sur ces écoles là sur ces classes
là malheureusement mardi nous avons un
comité technique académique où nous
avons déjà les premiers éléments de
chiffrage de ce que seront les deux
stations du département et nous sommes à
peu près certain que si ça permettra en
éducation prioritaire d'améliorer la
situation des cp et peut-être des cee
nous n'avons toujours pas d'information
en tout cas à terme ça va dégrader la
situation du reste des écoles et ça
évidemment ce n'est pas satisfaisant
j'ajouterai que ce qui se fait pourquoi
les autres écoles seraient impactés
négativement par ce que si vous voulez
le pour arriver à ouvrir les classes
nécessaires en éducation prioritaire
pour avoir ces classes dédoublées
il va falloir mans forcément redéployer
par ailleurs les moyens qui existent
donc ce qui veut dire que ça va se faire
au détriment la ville donnera par
exemple dit déjà que à la rentrée
prochaine elle ne sait pas comment va
diviser les places alors entre après il
ya des petites contingences matérielles
qui ne relève certainement pas du haut
commissariat à la pensée scientifique de
monsieur blanc caire mais qui sont de
l'ordre de assez basique du nombre de
chaises du nombre de tables du nombre de
classes etc
et peut-être aussi des moyens des
communes à pouvoir suivre et à pouvoir
financer cette montée en puissance deux
ans
union par classe pour éventuellement
répondre à ça ccpa 12 on serait des cpa
24 ou des soins à 24 avec deux
enseignants est ce que ça marche aussi
bien compensées ou alors c'est forcément
moins efficace alors écoutez ça marche
aussi bien je ne sais pas en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est que c'est un
dévoiement l'idée c'est quand même
d'avoir une petite structure parce qu'un
groupe class à vannes 4 y aurait-il deux
enseignants sein de la classe ça n'est
pas la même chose qu'un groupe place à
douze élèves
je vais vous donner des exemples moi je
connais beaucoup de collègues qui dans
leurs classes à 12 ont aménagé un coin
lecture d un des éléments qui permettent
vraiment d'améliorer le climat de classe
quand vous allez avoir 24 élèves par
classe de toute façon vous ne pourrez
pas le faire donc je crois que là encore
l'éducation nationale a fait preuve de
beaucoup de volontarisme de beaucoup de
coups de menton mais que derrière les
moyens ne suivent pas une fois de plus
c'est une bonne chose la diminution du
nombre d'élèves par classe mais ça ne
doit pas concerner que l'éducation
prioritaire et ça doit se faire dans des
conditions permettant d'accueillir les
élèves dans de bonnes conditions deux
questions encore très rapide sur le
retour de la dictée quotidien c'est un
choix aussi énoncé fin 2017 par le
ministre de l'éducation l'eau si vous
êtes plutôt critique ou alors vous dites
que c'est écoutez j'ai cru comprendre
que ce qu'ils avaient péché à mal de
dates fixes j'ai cru comprendre que ce
qu'ils avaient péché chez les élèves
étaient que précisément il avait une
difficulté dans l'accès au sens sur dans
les dernières études internationales
je ne répèterai pas que l'orthographe et
tu la science des ânes mais néanmoins on
peut considérer que quelqu'un et je
connais des élèves qui avaient une
orthographe parfaite pour autant ça ne
signifie pas qu'on a un accès au sens
parfait donc je crois qu'il faut se
garder là aussi une vision mécaniste
c'est pas parce que vous dis chiffre est
très bien un texte que vous le comprenez
et a contrario vous avez des élèves qui
ne décrivent pas forcément très bien
mais qu'ils comprennent parfaitement ce
qu'ils disent
enfin terminons sur l'école maternelle
ça concerne votre votre syndicat d
assise là aussi c'est très flou mais des
assises de la maternelle auront lieu en
mars
elles devront permettre d'évoquer tous
les sujets qui concernent la maternelle
est-ce que quelle est la priorité selon
vous aujourd'hui pour la maternelle est
ce que là aussi cessé les moyens peut
être humain qui manquent à écouter jeu
vite toute personne
sans être noro scientifique
décidément ça nous aura tenu tout le
monde il ya exactement à venir dans une
classe de grande section où il ya trente
trois élèves et a constaté que le temps
qui peut être consacré à chacun d'entre
eux alors je parle même pas des classes
de moyenne section de petites sections
pour constater que c'est quand même pas
facile
et j'ajouterai que un autre élément qui
est particulièrement significatif c'est
que depuis une dizaine d'années le
nombre d'élèves de toutes petites
sections l'accueil des 2 ans a été en
chute libre au niveau national toutes
catégories de deux contextes considéré
que ce soit en éducation prioritaire que
ce soir éducation prioritaire en zone
rurale et c'est donc avant de parler d'
assises de la maternelle
si les conclusions sont déjà dans les
tiroirs
évidemment nous aurons du mal à
départager merci bertrand en mesure
d'être venu sur ce plateau merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le co secrétaire départemental
du syndicat snuipp fsu merci à vous et
bon week-end et je suis on passe
maintenant à l'actualité de la semaine
[Musique]
l'actualité de cette semaine marquée
lundi par l'hommage rendu à clarisse à
cette policière a battu il ya trois ans
à la suite des attentats contre charlie
hebdo la ville de carrières sous poissy
où la policière habiter à organiser une
cérémonie en présence de la famille des
habitants et des écoliers qui ont
interprété des chants d'espoir pour
l'occasion une cérémonie devant le
square qui porte désormais son nom
propos recueillis par camille lambert
c'est pour ça qu'on a voulu que ce
square ici soient réalisés là où elle
courait et puisqu'on est vraiment sur
les lieux de vie de clarisse à un tous
les jours ou plusieurs fois par semaine
elle dit venez courir sur ses berges de
seine
donc c'est vraiment ces lieux de vie ces
lieux où elle est épanouie elle était
joyeuse et ses essais ça cette rupture
qui se fait quand il ya un assassinat
quand il ya une mort c'est cette rupture
de cette joie de vivre de cet
épanouissement qui est tout à coup
s'arrête qui met un terme à tout cet
investissement qui a été le sien auprès
de la république auprès des autres prêts
de la sécurité et ça je crois qu'il faut
pas l'oublier c'est ça qu'on veut
entretenir de sa mémoire à elle c'est un
livre qui retrace l'histoire récente de
trappes et qui fait beaucoup parler de
lui depuis une dizaine de jours la
communauté en ouvrage écrit par deux
journalistes du monde à ne rien de
chemin et raphaëlle bacqué elle évoque
dans une série de chapitres à ses cours
les faits marquants de la ville le
parcours de ces stars et personnages
emblématiques les deux auteurs étaient
nos invités mercredi soir sur le plateau
de grégory canal est extrait city une
ville où tout se passe de manière
exponentielle rhône a condamné c'est au
sens large c'est à dire que on pourrait
croire que c'est un roman mais ce n'est
pas un roman
et tout se passe de manière incroyable
par exemple les émeutes de 2005 et un
gardien qui meurt dans la cour du lycée
ensuite en 2013 on a dit ce sont des
premières émeutes contre des
commissariats
en france il ya une synagogue qui brûle
dans l'année 2000
il ya des stars inouïe qui sont nés à
trappes et que connaît la france entière
donc ça nous a paru passionnant c'est
aussi une histoire d'une étude plus
générale de la banlieue ce saut libre la
communauté oui surtout la banlieue vous
vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir elle
est toujours abordé de façon très
passionnelle avec à chaque fois des
positions politiques ou morales très
forte et nous on voulait revenir quelque
chose de beaucoup plus journalistique
vraiment une enquête détaillée nuance et
sans parti pris et qui permet de
raconter effectivement un bout de
l'histoire de france et l'ensemble de
cette interview est à retrouver sur
notre site internet
c'est officiel depuis mardi la vitesse
sur les routes secondaires à double sens
en séparateur central baissera le 1er
juillet pour passer de 90 à 80 km heure
face à cette mesure comment réagissent
les professionnels du territoire les
professionnels de la route qu'ils soient
libres ou taxi la réponse avec ce
reportage de camille lambert et patrick
jacques de dixmude
c'est pour ça que qui va empêcher les
actions c'est pas la vitesse
m'étonnerait ça m'étonnerait que laura
moye d'accédants à 10 km ça m'étonnerait
j'ai trouve à 80 kilomètres on peut
avoir des accédants à mortal réponses
auprès des particuliers l'annoncent ne
fait pas l'unanimité le gouvernement a
annoncé mardi 9 janvier la baisse de la
limitation de 90 à 80 km heure sur les
routes secondaires sans séparateur
central
les professionnels de la route on peut
aussi appris la nouvelle
pour ce chauffeur de taxi il faut
surtout changer les mentalités
le taux d'accidentologie pour moi je
trouve que
il a augmenté suite au comportement des
gens sur la route
donc nous en tant que professionnels de
la route on s'en rend bien le compte
bien sur l'aspect suffit que vous êtes
sur une voie vous êtes peut-être 5 ou 10
km h en dessous de la vitesse maximale
la personne derrière dégressive réunion
constat partagé par ce coursier qui
travaille sur les routes depuis 21 ans
pour lui le problème est avant tout
comportementale moi ce qui me fait peur
et ce que je remarque depuis un ou deux
ans et
c'est le téléphone portable je trouve
que c'est un véritable danger
je pense qu'une personne consciente qui
roulent à 90 en étant bien concentré sur
la route
je pense qu'elle est moins dangereuse
qu'une personne qui roule à 80 et qui
tapent des textos mais plus que le
téléphone l'alcool serait la première
cause de mortalité routière suivi par
les excès de vitesse depuis trois ans le
nombre de tués augmente en 2016 plus de
3400 personnes ont perdu la vie sur les
routes le accélère le rythme à quelques
semaines des annonces du gouvernement
les sept présidents des départements
d'île de france se sont réunis jeudi
pour dénoncer le projet de réforme de la
métropole du grand paris sans rencontres
officielles les départements s'inquiète
des fuites parues récemment dans la
presse des fuites qui font état d'un
projet a restreint dans ses frontières
actuelles et qui supprimerait les
départements de la petite couronne
écouter pierre bédier à ce sujet il faut
une région qui soit la métropole une
métropole qui soit la région peu importe
donc l'île de france
c'est une métropole et à l'intérieur de
cette métropole des élus qui existe et
des structures qui existent que les
départements donc la métropole prend
plus de pouvoir venant de l'état
c'est-à-dire le haut vers le bas
zone ont aussi du bas vers le haut les
départements on peut transférer à la
métropole la métropole belle même
transférer des actions qu'elle n'arrive
pas à faire elle même du sport également
dans l'actualité locale cette semaine et
du cyclisme précisément avec le parcours
officiel du paris nice 2018 qui a été
dévoilée c'était mardi à versailles
comme chaque année depuis neuf ans le
peloton s'élancera le dimanche 4 mars
depuis les yvelines chatou et la petite
commune d'orson ville seront les villes
étapes de ce tracé dans le département
miquel et demi d'euros pour les détails
après voilà si en 2017 c'est au tour de
chatou d'être ville départ du paris nice
le 4 mars prochain le peloton s'élancera
pour un départ fictif de l'île des
impressionnistes avant un départ réel à
fond que et cyclistes passeront ensuite
par villepreux et villiers saint
frédéric
avant de s'engouffrer dans la vallée de
chevreuse on va les chercher à coups de
boules et les trous on va aller chercher
la coupe de châteaufort mais côté stèle
jacques anquetil donc ça parle aussi des
mots c'était sont des endroits qui parle
et un retour sur saint quentin en
yvelines
bois d'arcy et après on sûr du
département à la celle saint cloud le
tracé de cette première étape de 135 km
a été imaginé pour apporter du suspense
à la course comme paris nice se joue à
quelques secondes près les secondes qui
seront prises ou perdu dès le premier
dimanche dans les humains contre ans
sans aucun depuis jours après sur la
promenade des anglais
le lendemain le peloton prendra le
départ de la deuxième étape depuis le
village d'orson vie d'une commune de
moins de 400 habitants située dans les
environs de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
moi je trouve ça bien parce que
le vélo c'est pas que le tour de france
des épreuves comme paris nice ça permet
aussi à des combines qui n'ont peut-être
pas toujours les moyens d'accueillir le
tour de france avant d'avoir une épreuve
cycliste de renault avec des coureurs de
renom et épi pas faire plaisir à tout le
monde aux habitants aux gamins des
écoles pas loin en quoi c'est bien une
nouvelle accueillie avec enthousiasme
par les habitants de la commune qui
pourront croiser les stars du cyclisme
français comme arnaud démare ou varennes
barguil oui je suis contente je suis pas
trop cyclisme moi mais mon conjoint je
suis donc on va sûrement aller voir les
les un coureur ça va peut-être dynamiser
un peu le village quoi là parce que
c'est un petit peu calme quoi découvrir
un peu au jour deux villages dans son
ville il fois le départ donné les 22
équipes cyclistes rouleront pendant
quatre kilomètres avant de quitter le
département des yvelines pour l'eure et
loir ils reviendront en 2019 pour une
nouvelle édition
c'est clean toujours avec son record qui
restera dans les mémoires c'est sûr à
100 6 ans robert marchand arrête la
compétition
souvenez vous il ya un an ce sportif pas
comme les autres établissait un record
du monde de l'heure des plus de 105 en
un peu plus de 22 km en 1h sur la piste
du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le souteneur
le centenaire excusez-moi raccroche sur
conseil de ses médecins
cette dernière performance en date un
titre de champion du monde amateur de
cyclisme sur piste
beaucoup en ont sûrement déjà profité
beaucoup vont en profiter ce week end
les soldes d'hiver ont débuté pour six
semaines ce mercredi et malgré une
baisse de la fréquentation des magasins
près de quatre français sur dix sont
allés dénicher les bonnes affaires dès
ce premier jour
mickeal et demi d'euros s'est rendu dans
les centres commerciaux de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reportages des
prix cassés un geste bien connu une
forte affluence au niveau des caisses
les soldes d'hiver ont officiellement
débuté ce mercredi 10 janvier dans cette
boutique de plaisir une dizaine de
clients n'ont pas hésité à se lever très
tôt pour trouver la perle rare
ah parce que tout simplement sa part
très vite et que jusqu'à -50 -60 kg dans
les bonnes tailles sa part le
premier jour où le premier week-end sur
un coup de chance on peut trouver des
choses mais c'est plus compliqué c'est
mieux on va dire parce que
malheureusement des fois on attend la
première des mains qu'on a pu les
tailles
c'est bien de devenir le premier jour
cette année les boutiques ont décidé de
baisser les prix dès le jour j pour
concurrencer les plateformes internet
les clients peuvent acheter des produits
au tarif de la deuxième démarque dès la
première semaine
allez on en profite mais da - du
pourcent supplémentaire des deux
articles achetés jusqu'à 14h faut en
profiter c'est maintenant on peut passer
d'un pull à 35 euros 99 un chemisier à
25 euros 99 ans elle est vraiment les
prix de nos jours ont plus augmenté
qu'auparavant donc du coup les seuls
sont vraiment plus intéressantes
aujourd'hui affluence des grands jours
également dans les centres commerciaux
de montigny le bretonneux dans ce
magasin spécialisé dans les collants
l'affluence et 40% plus élevé que sur un
jour classiques bas les gens attendez un
peu que ça allait salle dans un malgré
les ventes privées qui avait avant là ça
les arrange bien aussi de voir que
certains n'ont pas hésité à empiéter sur
la pause déjeuner pour faire chauffer la
carte bleue m'a dit que j'en avais
besoin mais du coup comme j'en ai vu à
-50% bas je les ai pris je n'aurais pas
pris 6 aurait été beau qu'on nous voilà
cette cliente repartira finalement avec
20 euros de colons dans son panier en
moyenne un français devraient dépenser
200 euros les soldes se termineront dans
six semaines le 20 février prochain
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo autour
de l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tv 60,18 bon week-end à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]